- Le premier médicament
qui ralentirait la progression
de la terrible maladie
d'Alzheimer vient d'être
approuvé aux États-Unis.
Aduhelm, un anticorps monoclonal
développé par la compagnie
Biogen.
NOUHA BEN GAIED, Fédération des
Sociétés alzheimer du Québec
- C'est une excellente nouvelle,
ça fait quand même plus
de 15 ans qu'on attendait
une nouvelle comme celle-ci.
Donc, c'est une grande journée
pour les personnes atteintes
de la maladie d'Alzheimer.
- Ce médicament permet de
combattre la formation de
plaques amyloïdes sur
les neurones du cerveau
des gens atteint d'Alzheimer.
Un phénomène qui, croit-on,
provoquerait de la démence
chez ceux qui en sont victimes.
Aduhelm ne serait efficace
qu'au stade précoce de la
maladie et il doit être pris
en continu, par intraveineuse.
- Ça a permis, en fait,
une diminution de la présence
des plaques beta-amyloïdes
dans le cerveau,
une amélioration des fonctions
cognitives et des fonctions
exécutives et même aussi,
jusqu'à un certain niveau,
une amélioration de ce
qu'on appelle "le fardeau
des proches-aidants".
- Il faut cependant rappeler
que l'approbation de ce produit
s'est faite dans la controverse.
En 2019, après des premiers
résultats cliniques décevants,
Biogen avait abandonné
ce traitement, puis elle a
redémarré une nouvelle étude
qui a été critiqué par les
experts avant d'obtenir
finalement une autorisation
de mise en marché.
JUDES POIRIER, Centre d'étude
prév. de la maladie d'Alzheimer
- On a réanalysé les données
d'une certain facon
et finalement on a vu
quelque chose de positif.
Mais l'effet sur la mémoire,
il est très modeste.
- Par contre, l'agence
américaine a imposé certaines
balises à la compagnie.
- La FDA a accepté le médicament
conditionnellement à une
troisième étude qui elle devra
clairement montrer l'efficacité
et le bénéfice pour le patient.
- La maladie d'Alzheimer
représente de 60 à 80 % des cas
de démence diagnostiqués.
Un demi-million de Canadiens
en souffrent et plus
de 150 000 Québécois.
Le coût du traitement est
estimé à quelques dizaines de
milliers de dollars par année,
une facture qui pourrait
être salée pour les systèmes
de santé qui accepteront
de le rembourser.
- Ça vaut la peine surtout
pour les personnes qui,
actuellement, reçoivent un
diagnostic et qui, pour eux,
il n'y a aucun espoir étant
donné que pour le moment,
la maladie d'Alzheimer est
une maladie incurable.
- Biogen n'a pas encore fait
de demande d'autorisation
de son médicament au Canada.
Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M